-L'ETENDARD SANGLANT EST LEVE
-Sur le fondement de l'article
49, alinéa 3
de la Constitution...
Huées
J'engage la responsabilité
de mon gouvernement...
-Ce devait être
la réforme phare
du second quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron.
-La réforme des retraites,
c'est une réforme essentielle
si on veut
préserver notre modèle social
quand on ne peut plus monter
les impôts.
Il n'y a qu'un moyen de faire,
si on est lucide :
comme nous vivons
plus longtemps,
c'est de travailler
plus longtemps.
-Elle a déclenché
la colère de la rue...
-On n'essaye pas de bloquer
le pays ou de mettre le bordel,
on dit que 64 ans, pour beaucoup,
c'est pas possible.
-...et enflammé
l'Assemblée nationale.
Brouhaha
-Vous êtes
un imposteur et un assassin !
-Des engagements...
-On n'est pas dans un amphi
ou une manif,
on est dans l'hémicycle
de l'Assemblée nationale !
-Entre l'obstruction de la gauche,
les atermoiements
des Républicains, les approximations
du gouvernement...
Retour sur un impossible débat
au palais Bourbon.
Moins de 10 jours
après l'annonce officielle
de la réforme des retraites,
les Français sont dans la rue,
à Paris
comme en province.
C'est du jamais vu
depuis des décennies :
les 8 principaux syndicats
du pays
appellent ensemble
à manifester.
Les députés de la NUPES,
l'alliance de gauche,
sont dans le cortège,
écharpes en bandoulière
et baskets aux pieds.
-Ici, vous pouvez
prendre les baskets
absolument légendaires
de Louis Boyard,
parce qu'il a mis sur Twitter
la tête de ses baskets
pour appeler à manifester.
Moi, j'ai fait
moins de buzz que lui,
mais je l'ai fait avec mes bottes.
-Il faut plus de courage
pour manifester avec des talons.
-Moi, si je suis à plat,
j'ai mal au dos.
C'est pas une histoire de courage
mais d'habitude.
Ca va ?
-Les insoumis,
les socialistes,
les communistes,
les écologistes...
-C'est une réunion de famille !
-La gauche affiche son unité
derrière les syndicats.
-Qui donne la direction ?
-Je vois rien.
-Tu vois rien ?
-On... On suit, quoi.
-C'est une bataille avant
l'ouverture du débat à l'Assemblée.
Les deux doivent se répondre :
c'est le nombre dans la rue
qui va permettre de mettre
la pression sur le gouvernement,
et à l'Assemblée
et au Sénat,
nous serons en écho
de ce qui se passe dans la rue.
-La NUPES veut mobiliser vite
pour contrer le gouvernement
qui a lancé
le compte à rebours.
Il a choisi une loi de financement
de la Sécurité sociale
qui lui permet de circonscrire
la durée des débats
à 50 jours au Parlement,
selon le désormais célèbre
article 47.1
de la Constitution.
-Le gouvernement veut passer
en force,
il a inventé ce 47.1,
qui est une sorte
de 49.3 low cost.
C'est une manière d'aller plus vite,
en espérant qu'il peut
couper l'herbe sous le pied
de la mobilisation.
Mais moi, j'ai en tête 2006.
Le CPE, il avait été voté,
la mobilisation a continué
et on a réussi à faire
que le gouvernement
retire son projet de loi.
-L'espoir est permis.
Cette première mobilisation
est un immense succès.
Il y avait entre 1 et 2 millions
de personnes
dans la rue.
Ils chantent des slogans.
Même si elle s'oppose
à la réforme,
Laure Lavalette
ne participe pas
aux manifestations.
Ce n'est pas dans l'ADN
de son parti,
le Rassemblement National.
A une semaine de l'arrivée
du projet de loi
à l'Assemblée,
la députée du Var
et ses collègues préfèrent fourbir
leurs armes parlementaires.
Ils ne déposeront
que très peu d'amendements.
-L'idée, c'est de balayer
chaque article,
de voir ce qu'on fait
comme amendement.
Est-ce qu'on en garde
pour la séance,
est-ce qu'on en fait
dès la commission ?
Ce qu'il faut,
c'est qu'on puisse,
au-delà de dénoncer
la réforme...
-Proposer.
-Parler de la proposition
de Marine.
-Le message est clair,
on l'a défendu
toute l'année dernière
pendant la campagne présidentielle,
c'est la simplicité
de notre message :
si vous avez commencé à travailler
entre 17 et 20 ans,
vous pouvez partir à la retraite
à 60 ans avec 48 annuités pleines.
Après, c'est progressif
jusqu'à 62 ans.
-S'il veut faire adopter
sa réforme, Emmanuel Macron
a clairement besoin d'alliés,
puisqu'il n'a pas de majorité
absolue à l'Assemblée nationale.
Alors, depuis des semaines,
le gouvernement négocie
avec la droite, qui défend
depuis longtemps un report
de l'âge de la retraite.
Les Républicains ont en main
le destin du projet de loi.
-Tous mes voeux
pour cette nouvelle année,
le meilleur.
-Le député Stéphane Viry
est l'un des chefs de file
de son groupe dans ce dossier.
Dans son fief des Vosges,
il a rendez-vous
avec ses militants locaux...
-On s'installe ?
-...à qui il résume
le dilemme des Républicains.
-Si on est pour...
Le RN va nous taper dessus
à bras raccourcis :
on est la majorité,
on est macronistes,
il n'y a donc plus
que le RN qui représente
une opposition
et une alternance.
Si on est contre...
Alors qu'il y a des mesures
qui vont dans la finalité
de ce que pense la droite :
travailler plus longtemps,
consolider le système
de retraites.
Si on est contre,
ceux qui pensent
que la droite
doit être responsable
vont nous dire :
"Vraiment, vous êtes contre tout,
vous servez à rien."
Donc quoi qu'il arrive,
le temps politique
de ce début d'année
pour Les Républicains est compliqué.
-Les Républicains hésitent,
la gauche est vent debout,
le Rassemblement National aussi,
la rue est mobilisée.
Le dossier des retraites
s'annonce explosif
à l'Assemblée.
La députée Renaissance
Stéphanie Rist
a la lourde tâche d'être rapporteur
de ce projet de loi.
-Notre objectif est
d'examiner le texte,
donc d'arriver à faire
que cet examen du texte
soit possible.
Il y a 2 façons
que ce soit possible :
que les débats se passent
correctement,
de façon respectueuse
d'un côté et de l'autre,
et l'autre c'est aussi
de voir si on a
une majorité ou pas
sur ce texte.
Enfin, moi,
je suis plutôt optimiste,
à ce jour et en même temps,
consciente que les mouvements
sociaux qui existent
sont à prendre en compte
dans le fait
que des députés
pourraient changer d'avis.
-A 10 jours du débat
dans l'hémicycle,
la députée a rendez-vous
avec Franck Riester,
le ministre chargé
des relations
avec le Parlement.
-Ca va ?
-Ouais.
-Il s'inquiète du grand nombre
d'amendements
qui pourraient bloquer
l'examen du texte.
D'habitude, t'es à 1500...
-On aura du mal à aller au bout.
-Oui.
-Dans tous ces amendements,
il y aura forcément
des amendements qui sont là
pour faire perdre du temps,
donc une forme d'obstruction.
-Le gouvernement garde le souvenir
cuisant de la précédente
tentative de réforme
des retraites.
La France Insoumise va-t-elle,
comme en 2019,
emboliser l'Assemblée
avec des amendements
avec, cette année,
4 fois plus de députés
et le renfort
de ses alliés de la NUPES ?
-On doit aussi définir la stratégie
qu'on va avoir ensemble
dès la semaine prochaine.
Ca, on va en parler après.
-Une stratégie
qui sera définie
loin des caméras,
une stratégie
tout aussi offensive
qu'en 2019,
mais plus imprévisible
pour tenter de maîtriser
le temps parlementaire.
-Il y aura des milliers
d'amendements,
ça c'est sûr,
qui seront sur le fond,
à chaque fois,
et qui peuvent soit
être maintenus jusqu'au bout,
soit être retirés,
donc on va ajuster
notre stratégie
au fur et à mesure,
avec un objectif :
ne pas faciliter la tâche
du gouvernement
mais le combattre,
en écho avec la mobilisation,
et un deuxième objectif
qui est d'avoir le débat
sur l'article 7.
-L'article 7 repousse l'âge légal.
C'est le coeur de la réforme.
Dans la rue,
la pression s'accentue
pour dire non aux 64 ans.
Tout est prêt pour un combat
parlementaire intense.
Musique dynamique
6 février.
Au palais Bourbon,
c'est le jour J
pour la réforme
des retraites.
...
-Ca va ?
T'es prête ?
-Oui, ça va.
...
-L'heure est encore
à la détente.
Les députés Renaissance
se réunissent
autour d'un verre
pour se donner du courage.
Stéphanie Rist se prépare
à deux semaines
de marathon parlementaire.
...
-L'article 20, y a peu de chances
qu'on y arrive.
-Ah bon ?
-Le 7, on va y aller.
Mais le 20, je sais pas.
-Oui.
-L'opposition a déposé
plus de 20 000 amendements.
Alors, le camp présidentiel
sait déjà
que le projet de loi
ne pourra pas être examiné
dans son intégralité.
-On s'attend à ce que ce soit
un peu difficile,
mais on va pas s'ennuyer.
Faut regarder
le côté positif.
C'est beaucoup d'amendements
pour arriver
à ce toute 1re partie.
Peut-être que d'un coup,
ils seront retirés
donc ça nécessite
d'être bien en cohésion
et de bien être présents
parce qu'ils retireront pas
leurs amendements
au moment
où on sera tous là.
-A quelques minutes
du début des hostilités,
les 150 députés de gauche
font une démonstration
de force.
-Le gouvernement peut faire
les circonvolutions qu'il veut.
La vérité,
que chacun aura compris,
c'est qu'il n'y a pas
plus injuste
pour les carrières pénibles,
les carrières longues
ceux qu'on a applaudis à 20h,
que cette réforme.
Nous, à l'unisson,
c'est non.
-Les députés
du Rassemblement National, eux,
ne sont que 88,
mais ils sont en compétition
avec la NUPES,
pour s'afficher
comme les principaux opposants
à Emmanuel Macron.
Marine Le Pen a donc décidé
de déposer une motion
pour pousser le gouvernement
à organiser un référendum.
-Ce sujet des retraites
représente
un réel choix de société.
Il n'est donc pas aberrant
qu'il soit tranché par référendum.
De nature optimiste,
j'espère encore
qu'une majorité de députés
va voter cette motion,
à commencer par ceux de la NUPES,
qui devraient faire leurs
les paroles
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon :
"Je mets au défi
"les autres partis
d'opposition
"d'adopter
la motion référendaire."
-Marine Le Pen met la NUPES
au pied du mur,
mais elle sait bien
que la gauche
ne votera jamais
avec le Rassemblement National
et que sa demande
de référendum
ne sera qu'un coup d'épée
dans l'eau.
Musique intrigante
...
-Bonjour à tous.
La séance est ouverte.
-Dès le début,
le ton est donné.
Brouhaha et applaudissements
L'ordre du jour appelle
la discussion du projet de loi
de financement rectificatif
de la Sécurité sociale
pour 2023.
La parole est à monsieur
Olivier Dussopt,
ministre du Travail,
du Plein emploi
et de l'Insertion.
La parole est
à monsieur Olivier Dussopt,
ministre du Travail...
La foule hue.
Non, pas de chahut !
Non !
Monsieur Dussopt ?
-Madame la présidente...
Brouhaha
Madame la présidente...
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés...
...
Nous y sommes.
-Vous laissez parler
le ministre !
-Merci.
Je disais, madame la présidente...
-Non, s'il vous plaît !
Ne frappez pas les pupitres !
La parole est
au gouvernement.
-Madame...
-Le ministre ne parvient pas
à commencer
son discours.
...
-Ah non ! Ah non !
-Merci, madame...
-Vous croyez
qu'on va passer 15 jours
comme cela dans l'hémicycle ?
-OUI !
-Oui ?
-Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés,
nous y sommes,
quand bien même
vous ne le voudriez pas.
Des engagements...
-On n'est pas dans un amphi
ni dans une manif,
mais dans l'hémicycle
de l'Assemblée nationale !
-Il faudra presque une heure
à Olivier Dussopt
pour entamer son propos.
Brouhaha
-Je le disais
il y a un instant...
-L'examen du projet de loi
s'annonce difficile
pour le gouvernement,
mais il est prêt au bras de fer.
-N'ayons pas peur de le dire.
En matière de retraites,
c'est une réforme
ou la faillite.
C'est ça, la réalité
de notre système aujourd'hui !
-Dès le lendemain,
les Français
sont à nouveau dans la rue.
Après cette première journée
chaotique
de discussions,
les syndicats
mettent désormais
la pression
sur le gouvernement
et l'Assemblée nationale.
-Quand le gouvernement
dit que c'est soit cette réforme,
soit la faillite,
on sait que c'est faux,
il y a d'autres solutions.
L'obstruction pour l'obstruction,
ça ne sert à rien.
Aujourd'hui, le débat parlementaire
n'est pas à la hauteur.
-Où est-ce que ça bloque ?
C'est pas chez nous !
On n'est pas en train
de bloquer le pays,
mais d'expliquer
que les 64 ans,
pour nombre de travailleurs,
c'est pas possible.
Il faut que le gouvernement
et le Parlement entendent.
-Dans le cortège parisien
de cette 3e manifestation,
il y a aussi Les Insoumis,
et surtout, le premier
d'entre eux.
Même s'il n'est plus député,
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
surveille de près
ce qui se passe à l'Assemblée
et veut toujours
donner le ton.
-Nous défendrons autant
d'amendements qu'il le faut,
la nuit, le jour,
les week-ends,
et ça s'appelle pas
de l'obstruction
mais du débat.
C'est comme ça.
Au Parlement,
on vient pour parler.
Ceux qui veulent se taire
restent chez eux.
-Au Parlement,
on ne se tait pas.
C'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire.
Le débat n'avant
que très lentement.
-Pour le Rassemblement National,
M. Thomas Ménagé.
-Au total, il y a plus
de 20 000 amendements
sur le projet de loi,
dont 18 000 déposés
par la NUPES.
-Retirez vos amendements !
Ne servez pas la soupe
au gouvernement !
Vous les aidez !
Ils sont heureux de ne pas
parler du fond, de passer
des heures sur ce qui
n'intéresse pas les Français !
Ce qui les intéresse,
c'est la pénibilité !
-Au bout de quatre jours,
seul l'article 1,
mettant fin aux régimes spéciaux,
a été adopté.
Mais cette lenteur
ne fait-elle pas
les affaires du camp présidentiel,
qui n'est pas sûr
d'avoir une majorité ?
-En tant que rapporteur,
j'ai envie qu'on puisse
examiner l'ensemble
des articles,
qu'on puisse débattre,
améliorer le texte.
Ca sert à quoi d'autre,
en étant député,
que de pouvoir améliorer
les textes ?
Si on est là
pour des tribunes
qui peuvent se faire ailleurs,
faisons-les ailleurs.
Mais dans l'hémicycle,
travaillons sur le texte.
-La semaine va se terminer
comme elle a commencé :
sous haute tension.
C'est un tweet
qui crée l'étincelle,
celui du député Insoumis
Thomas Portes.
Sur cette photo,
il pose avec, aux pieds,
un ballon à l'effigie
du ministre Olivier Dussopt.
Alors, quand le député veut prendre
la parole,
l'hémicycle s'embrase.
-Monsieur Portes.
-Ah !
Faibles applaudissements
-Madame la présidente,
messieurs les ministres.
Calmez-vous, collègues,
il y a pas de ballon, ici.
Exclamations choquées
-Vous vous exposez,
sourire aux lèvres,
avec votre écharpe tricolore,
foulant des pieds,
écrasant de vos pieds
la tête d'un ministre
de la République.
C'est, ni plus, ni moins,
un appel au meurtre.
Ni plus, ni moins,
-Monsieur Portes,
je crois que
l'hémicycle vous demande
des excuses.
Exclamations satisfaites
-Je retirerai mon tweet
le jour où vous retirerez
cette réforme qui va sacrifier
des milliers de gens !
-La séance est interrompue.
Après deux heures de réunion
des instances de l'Assemblée,
la sanction tombe :
Thomas Portes est exclu
pour 15 jours du palais Bourbon.
La 1re semaine de débat se termine,
alors qu'un seul
des 20 articles du projet de loi
a été voté.
Musique de tension
Les esclandres
et la lenteur des discussions
attisent la colère
de l'intersyndicale
et d'une partie
de l'opinion publique.
*"Bella Ciao"
Les syndicats pressent les députés.
*-O partigiano portami via
O bella ciao bella ciao
bella ciao ciao ciao
-Ce qu'il se passe
à l'Assemblée
ne sert pas...
- mais je ne suis pas le seul
à le penser, -
...ce qu'on est train de faire
dans la rue.
Moi, c'est pour ça que je pose
comme ambition,
et Philippe Martinez
et d'autres aussi,
qu'a minima,
l'article 7 soit en débat
à l'Assemblée cette semaine.
On souhaite qu'il soit mis en débat.
Il s'agit de ça
pour des millions de gens
et ce n'est pas en débat.
...
-La dernière semaine de débat
démarre.
Les députés parviendront-ils
à discuter
de ce fameux article 7 ?
Celui qui reporte
l'âge de la retraite à 64 ans.
Les débats de fond
vont-ils enfin
pouvoir commencer ?
-Monsieur Dussopt.
Puisque vous avez voulu parler
des morts du travail,
je vous donne les chiffres :
entre 2017 et 2019,
c'est 33 % d'accidents du travail
causant la mort en plus.
Vous avez la responsabilité
de ces choix politiques !
Vous êtes un imposteur
et un assassin !
-Les propos du député Insoumis
provoquent un tollé.
Même les alliés de la NUPES
se désolidarisent.
L'alliance de gauche se craquelle.
...
-Tenir de tels propos
est absolument inacceptable !
Nous sommes ici...
Nous sommes ici pour nous combattre,
mais jamais,
je dis bien jamais,
nos débats,
nos arguments ne doivent dériver
avec des insultes portées contre
des membres de cette Assemblée
et du gouvernement.
Applaudissements nourris
-J'ai eu,
il y a quelques instants,
à ce micro, des mots
que l'émotion et l'emportement
m'ont fait mal choisir
et qui sont déplacés.
Je souhaite évidemment les retirer
et adresser
des excuses publiques au ministre.
Applaudissements
-L'incident est clos.
Le débat reprend sur l'article 2.
-Mesdames et messieurs
les députés...
-Malgré tout,
la NUPES veut démontrer son unité
et donner des gages aux syndicats.
Le soir même, en choeur,
les quatre groupes de gauche
retirent une partie
de leurs amendements.
-Nous avons travaillé ensemble
pour pouvoir retirer
un millier d'amendements ce soir,
qui nous permettra
de passer à la suite.
-On est maîtres du calendrier.
On le prouve en accélérant.
-Il y a désormais l'espoir
que la discussion avance,
mais elle s'avère
de plus en plus compliquée
pour l'exécutif...
-Le scrutin est ouvert.
-...qui subit un gros revers.
Protestations
-Le scrutin est clos.
-Les députés retoquent l'article 2,
qui crée un index senior.
-Pour : 203. Contre : 256.
L'Assemblée nationale...
Vives protestations
...n'a pas adopté.
-Coup dur pour l'exécutif.
Cela confirme qu'il n'a pas,
pour le moment,
de majorité
pour faire voter sa réforme.
Alors, pour s'assurer
du soutien ferme des LR,
la Première ministre fait
des concessions
sur les carrières longues
pour ceux qui ont commencé
à travailler tôt.
Sauf que le gouvernement a
bien du mal
à expliquer
les nouvelles mesures.
-On entendra très clairement
ses propos. Monsieur le ministre.
Protestations
Chut.
-Concernant les demandes
de précisions qui ont été faites,
j'ai dit à plusieurs reprises
que le dispositif carrières longues
se caractérise
par des conditions cumulatives.
C'est le cas depuis 2003.
Dans le cadre du dispositif
de carrières longues,
il n'y aura aucune exigence
de durée d'affiliation au régime
supérieure à 43 ans
quand nous serons à une durée
de 43 ans, de montée en charge...
-Bonsoir à tous.
-Le gouvernement
qui fait un pas vers vous ?
-On n'a rien compris et ça commence
à devenir absolument insupportable.
Le gouvernement nous a fait
une annonce il y a quelques jours,
qui est devenue incompréhensible
au fur et à mesure des explications.
J'ai posé une question simple
à Olivier Dussopt en lui demandant
si quelqu'un qui avait commencé
à 14, 16 ou à 18 ans,
au jour de son anniversaire,
partirait bien avec 43 annuités
ou 44 annuités,
et le ministre s'obstine
à ne pas répondre à cette question.
C'est insupportable.
On ne tirera rien de ces débats.
-Dans les entreprises...
-Sur les revalorisations
des petites retraites,
ce n'est pas plus clair.
Est-ce que les 1200 euros
concerneront
1,8 million de retraités,
40 000, 12 000 ?
-Je désespère
et nous désespérant vraiment
d'avoir une réponse aux mêmes
questions qui nous taraudent
et nous languissons
pour avoir votre réponse,
monsieur le ministre Dussopt !
S'il vous plaît,
combien de personnes
qui partent à la retraite,
ou qui sont déjà
à la retraite,
verront leur rémunération
augmenter jusqu'à 1200 euros,
leurs pensions ?
-Les débats de fond viennent
enfin de commencer,
au bout de huit jours
de discussions.
Pour accélérer,
les écologistes,
les communistes,
les socialistes enlèvent tous
leurs amendements avant l'article 7,
celui sur les 64 ans.
-Nous avons décidé
de retirer
tous les amendements
que nous avions déposés
jusqu'à l'article 7,
puisque nous avons entendu,
nous avons compris
qu'un certain nombre
de femmes et d'hommes,
de force, souhaitaient
que nous puissions arriver
à cette discussion
de l'article 7.
-Mais les insoumis rechignent.
Et Jean-Luc Mélenchon,
dans un tweet,
révèle la véritable stratégie
de la France Insoumise :
ne pas aller à l'article 7.
-Ca veut dire quoi ?
"On sait qu'on est minoritaires.
"On n'a pas de majorité
pour mettre en échec
"le gouvernement et il faut
faire traîner les débats."
C'est ça que vous dites ?
C'est l'aveu de Jean-Luc Mélenchon.
Et regardez ce qui se passe
dans l'hémicycle.
Les socialistes sont partis.
Il reste trois écologistes.
Les communistes,
il reste en trois.
Il n'y a que LFI,
car les autres partagent pas
votre obstruction.
-Le temps de débat imparti
est bientôt écoulé.
Le dernier jour
ne permet pas
d'avancer plus.
Les députés ont
à peine entamé l'étude
de l'article 3.
-Dans moins de 10 minutes,
ce débat sur la réforme
des retraites
va malheureusement se terminer
dans notre hémicycle
et on compte sur le Sénat
pour faire un travail
que nous n'avons pas pu faire
ici à cause des députés
de La France Insoumise.
-Je dois vous dire
que je suis...
Je suis consterné.
-Le Parlement ne pourra pas,
il reste six minutes,
délibérer sur cette loi
parce que vous avez choisi
un calendrier parlementaire
contraint.
Les députés comptent à rebours.
-Merci.
-Aux 12 coups de minuit,
tout s'arrête.
11 000 amendements
et 18 articles
n'ont pas été examinés.
-Dans le respect
de la Constitution,
nos débats prennent fin.
Les députés chantent.
-Les députés insoumis entonnent
le chant des gilets jaunes.
Ambiance surréaliste
dans les travées.
-ON EST LA
-Députés insoumis,
vous m'avez insulté
15 jours.
Vous sortez,
mais vous m'avez insulté.
Personne n'a craqué.
Personne n'a craqué
et nous sommes là
devant vous,
pour la réforme !
-La réforme part au Sénat,
alors que les députés n'auront
jamais discuté de l'article 7
qui impose la retraite
à 64 ans.
-NOUS ON EST LA
-Au Palais du Luxembourg,
les débats sont longs,
mais plus sereins qu'à l'Assemblée.
Les sénateurs,
en majorité de droite,
votent très largement
pour la réforme des retraites.
Les sénateurs applaudissent.
-Retour au Palais Bourbon,
l'Assemblée doit valider
l'ultime version
du projet de loi, fruit
d'un compromis entre sept députés
et sept sénateurs.
La première ministre
dispose-t-elle d'une majorité
pour le voter ?
Toute la matinée, le gouvernement
fait et refait ses calculs.
Et le compte n'y est pas.
Un quart d'heure
avant le début de la séance,
il tranche
en faveur du 49.3.
Avec huit minutes de retard,
et Elisabeth Borne
arrive à l'Assemblée.
-Mes chers collègues...
La parole est
à madame la Première ministre.
Les députés la huent.
-Dans un hémicycle bondé,
cette fois,
ce n'est pas le chant
des gilets jaunes,
mais "La Marseillaise"
que les insoumis font retentir
pour couvrir la voix
de la Première ministre.
-L'ETENDAR SANGLANT EST LEVE
ENTENDEZ-VOUS
DANS VOS CAMPAGNES
-Elisabeth Borne
dégaine le 49.3
et règle ses comptes
avec la NUPES,
le Rassemblement National
et Les Républicains.
-Cet après-midi,
je n'ai pas envie
de revenir
sur les échappées personnelles
qui peuvent faire oublier à certains
les positions qu'ils défendaient
quelques mois plus tôt
avec leur famille politique.
-QU'UN SANG
-Cet après-midi,
je n'ai pas envie de revenir
non plus sur le comportement
de ceux qui ont tout fait
pour bloquer le débat
et se sont contentés
de multiplier
les insultes,
les excès
et les attaques.
Applaudissements
Enfin, cet après-midi,
je n'ai pas envie de revenir
sur le mutisme de ceux,
à l'extrême droite
de cet hémicycle
qui sont restés tapis
dans l'ombre
tout au long des débats
qui ont préféré se taire,
profitant en silence
des outrances des uns
et des revirements
des autres.
Cris divers
Aussi sur le fondement
de l'article 49.3
de la Constitution...
Les députés la huent.
...j'engage la responsabilité
de mon gouvernement...
-Aucune motion de censure
n'ayant été votée,
la réforme des retraites
est définitivement adoptée.
Après 50 jours de bras de fer
et un 49.3,
la victoire a un goût amer
pour le gouvernement.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA